what's up guys bang bang this video is
brought to you by prime
xbt they are a crypto trading platform
that has an
excellent award-winning environment for
margin trading
if you want to go check out their crypto
trading be sure to check out their copy
trading module which allows you to
replicate the trades of the most
successful traders with a proven track
record
if you're interested you can register
with the link below and you can get a 50
deposit bonus go check them out at prime
xbt
and let's get into this interview
all right guys bang bang neil is here
how are you doing sir thank you so much
for doing
this thanks very much for having me on
absolutely uh you work at diginex which
is the
first company with a crypto exchange
that is publicly traded in the united
states
uh which is on the nasdaq uh
under the equos uh ticker there um talk
a little bit just about your background
and how do you
get to diginex how do you guys get
listed etc
sure happy too um my background's i'm in
engineer by academic training so i'm an
aeronautical engineer
um i blame tom cruise for that anyone
who's seen top gun
that was that was really my introduction
to aircraft and
planes and everything about aircraft
that really wanted me to
be a pilot and an engineer and
everything that and how that works
um but i was graduating university so i
grew up in the northern part of the uk
went to university in uk and i was
graduating university around the time of
the dot-com bubble and then
um a lot of investment banks at the time
spending a lot of time at university
coming and trying to attract talent and
and bring people not just necessarily
with the financial background
you know into the industry um and i sat
through a couple of these
milk rounds as they were called and
listened and got interested and thought
maybe that was actually the career i
wanted and
before i knew it i'd done an internship
in the city in london and then graduated
took a job
a company called casino snap political
model um
and spent a number of years working
there um
i've so been in sort of traditional
finance if you like for about 20 years
prior to
prior to crypto i'm proud of joining
digitalx and that's taken me
from london to tokyo to hong kong
which is where i'm currently based um
so that's sort of that time
within the industry within the border
sort of financial services industry up
i've had the pleasure of you know being
involved in the sales and distribution
process
running research teams particularly
around the director's products and then
most
recently running trading desks trading
risk
i'm managing capital um you know with
the perspective of trying to use these
products to
um to generate returns
but in reality um you know two decades
is quite a long time
and you start to see things change and
you start to see you know what's having
an impact in the world and how you can
make an impact
and particularly how you can make an
impact within an institution
um and and within an industry that
really has so much inertia against
change
um despite it having a lot of the
brightest minds around
there really is a large initiative and
also sort of posts
you know the global financial crisis a
slight stigma attached to it
um you know with regards to how banks
were operating during that time
and what was being done and really that
gave me an opportunity to sort of step
back
think and and address the issues that
were not
not being able to change in the
financial services industry and then see
this sort of new growth of a product and
a new asset class come out and say okay
how can i take what i've learned in the
last two decades and then apply it to
this new asset class
that you could see was having some
teething problems and still does
and how can we try and find that middle
ground between
um between what traditional finance is
doing and then what's available in
crypto
so the opportunity presented itself to
to move into the crypto space
and i know that you've met richard and
he's been on your show and he's done a
great job
you know speaking with him and um he and
i had worked together so richard and i
and the former founder of
digium itself all work together in tokyo
we kind of grew up in finance a bit
together there
and um he'd often talk to me about
coming to join him because he'd left
and sort of been at the genesis of
diginex ahead of me and
talked to me about it and got me
interested in it and then finally when i
decided that the
um the sort of the risk reward was was
strong enough and this award is
something that we're thinking about all
the time
when that balance tipped it it became
natural for me to go and work with
people i knew i trusted
and people who i who understood the
deficiencies in
encrypted and deficiencies in in
traditional finance and how we can work
to
offset both of those to bring you know
some some real rigidity and
infrastructure to a
business that kind of needed it but at
the same time understand where
the um the incumbency in traditional
finance was really holding it back
and so when you think through kind of uh
diginex today
um how do you kind of outline the
business right
you guys have done so much you have so
many different products
just walk us through what the kind of
structure of the product suite is
sure i mean when you think about
products and
you know we think about cryptocurrencies
it's quite easy to sort of say
okay we'll start with with one central
piece an exchange there's a number of
them around
you know i'm sure your listeners are
aware of so many of them
but to us it wasn't just having an
exchange
it's all the other pieces of the
ecosystem you need to build
into that exchange to allow people to
say not only can i come here and trade
and transact
but how can i do that safely how can i
do that securely so i need a
i need a custody solution so we
naturally need to have a custody
solution and digivolt is our custody
solution that
we're extremely proud of you know is um
is being recognized and this week was
recognized as
you know one of the best uh custody
offerings you know
that's out there on the street um so we
have to add that to it then we need to
think about
okay you know how do people actually
want to transact
yes we have a ui and api fees for people
to be able to trade on the platform
but also they want to do a little bit
more than that so we have
you know access product which is
effectively uh an order and execution
management system
that not just interacts with our
exchange but a whole
number of other exchanges and one of the
points i'll make later is
we're not so um arrogant to assume that
ours is the only exchange out there and
as the only one we should look at we're
extremely proud of it and we believe
what we're doing is the right thing
but we also recognize that people know
what they like
or people are used to things so getting
them to move is sometimes quite
difficult
so rather than ignore all of those
people we want to enable them to trade
better too and that's what we've done
with
with diginex access which is our which
is our order management and trading
system
and then also around that we see
cryptocurrencies as a subset of the
larger digital assets
piece peace and so looking ahead
at where we could go with digital assets
and effectively
you know capital structures looking at
how they can use the blockchain
technology to do something
truly innovative in the future is what
we're doing with with our capital or
equos capital business which is
effectively our
uh equivalent to an investment banking
or corporate
um advisory firm and putting all of that
together
then sort of gives you an understanding
that really what we're looking at is the
whole ecosystem
and really what we're trying to solve
for is that liquidity issue and
how can we bring people together to
transact with each other
in a safe secure way you know in a
liquid way
and something that gives true
transparency around price and execution
got it and so what i want to spend today
talking about is
uh the derivatives business that you
guys are building and you have a very
unique view i think of derivatives
uh one from just the importance that it
will hold in the industry
um but also kind of how to address it as
uh an institutional
product and uh infrastructure so maybe
let's just start with
for like the people who don't know let's
just start one on one like what is a
derivative and why is it important
sure and i think just the concepts and
derivatives scare people a lot
um and we want to just dispel that myth
um you know regulators are often
concerned about them
and that talk about the risks that they
bring
um but to us in many ways it's a lot
about risk management and actually what
derivatives allow is
as a is your ability to reduce risk so
essentially a derivative is
is getting economic exposure to an
underlying asset class without
actually having to earn that asset class
and the most common ones you'll come
across will be
futures and options um now
every day in traditional finance these
trade in inordinate amounts of size
and are being used by retail and
institutions across the board
um i think what where we've looked at it
is
you can't really build an institutional
or asset class
business without understanding that you
need the derivative space
and and really it's about educating
not just our customers on the platform
but also working with the regulators
to ensure that they're comfortable with
the way we're doing it to draw those
parallels with the derivatives worlds
that's used
or the derivatives methods that are used
in traditional finance but also
understanding where the benefits for
specifically in this case cryptocurrency
derivatives you know could really play
out
um so really that that's that's the
ethos that's the thinking
um the kind of the key piece for us is
really
okay how do we how do we give access to
all of our customers for that
product because there are a number of
other derivatives exchanges out there
and we are gonna and we're doing it
differently from them um
you know and we're trying to find that
bridge between the two
so we have currently uh futures live on
our platform
you know we will have options trading um
you know in the coming months and
quarters um but we're going to do them
slightly differently to some of the
other platforms you might know in the
derivative space
but also slightly differently from how
you might have seen options trade in the
um
in traditional finance so talk through a
little bit about that
nuance in terms of how you guys view it
differently than other people in the
industry
sure um i think this
the key element for us is um is how we
manage
customers risk on the platform so as
most people are aware you can come and
trade the most simple derivative out
there is a future
um and people will talk about
um leverage it's a fairly common phase
you can go on to a
crypto exchange and trade 100 leverage
uh
future the reality is that future's not
leveraged at all
it's the platform that gives you
leverage and understanding that subtle
difference
might not impact most people on a
day-to-day basis because they see them
as one and the same
but there's a very specific difference
between a leveraged product and getting
leverage
on a product and what we want to do is
make sure people understand that
difference so you don't
you're not buying a product that's
inherently leveraged you're using your
capital
to allow you to buy more of a product
with less money and your leverage is in
is in the way you use your capital not
in the way the product itself is
structured
and i think that's important that people
understand that because you're not
forced to take risks you don't want to
take
you can go and buy a three or four or
ten times levied
etf for example on on an index
every unit of that you buy you have 10
times as much exposure
now you can roughly do the same thing by
buying 10 times
as many futures you know with the same
amount of capital
but at any point you could reduce that
number so i might not want to have 10
times as much exposure i could
you know by five or two or whatever it
might be and so understanding that
you're really in control of
of of how you get exposure and how you
take risk is a key thing
and then understanding how we help you
manage that
in a fair and transparent way and i
think that's one of the fundamental
differences
in terms of allowing our customers to
get access to these products we're not
trying equals we see ourselves as a
platform it's a utility we're here to
provide people a safe
place to transact we're not here to make
money
from people who don't understand
necessarily the risks that they're
taking
and so we want to make sure that the
processes that we put in place that
that mitigates your risk on that
platform are done fairly they're done
transparently
we're not actually trying to make money
from
other people's misfortune or
misunderstanding of products we don't
want that
what we want to do is make sure what we
want to do is
is provide that marketplace and and the
utility
and really it's about how we educate
people to use these products properly
but then also how we ensure that when
they are using them they're doing it in
a safe way
talk through kind of why somebody would
use this i know that you guys think a
lot about risk management you think a
lot about capital efficiency
but just explain those a little bit more
and kind of just
walk me through somebody coming to your
platform that wants to use these
derivatives
kind of what they can expect in both the
risk management bucket and the capital
efficiency side
sure so if you imagine there's probably
a lot of people for whom
owning and maintaining a balance of
bitcoin is a key part of their
their own personal balance sheet
that's becoming a more prevalent view
and we all understand a lot of the
fundamental economic reasons
as to why that view is becoming more and
more mainstream
now you can go on to a number of
different exchanges and buy some bitcoin
uh you could do it even often exchange
and you can hold it in a while and we've
already talked
about the custody piece of so that
pieces is already in place
now i guess the difference that we want
to talk about is
when you combine both derivatives
exchange and the spot exchange together
and you understand that people are
looking at that holistically
i might own some bitcoin but i might
have the view that in the short term
as we're seeing right now you might get
a small correction in the price
i might say that i'm okay i'm happy with
that i can i can live with that sort of
p l fluctuation in my life or i might
say look
you know i can feel the supply demand
dynamic because you know we might
have gone a little bit ahead of
ourselves too quickly or we've not
pulled back enough yet for people to
start again
um and i'd like to protect myself for
that so
what i can do then is sit with my core
bitcoin holding and
maybe i want to sell some futures
against it so my exposure to bitcoin
reduces
um but it doesn't cost me i don't ever
sell my actual bitcoin
i just sell some of my exposure to my
bitcoin but what
happened is because we understand that
you have some bitcoin
and you sold some exposure to bitcoin
you don't have any risk to us
so we're not going to charge you to do
that so we won't charge you margin on
your
short position because we know you have
a long position
now ironically if you've done that on
two different platforms platform a
doesn't know what platform b is doing
so they will charge you because they
don't understand your whole risk
so again it's about building that
ecosystem understanding that
we want to look at risk holistically we
want to look at your whole portfolio and
if you show us your whole portfolio
we'll allow you to manage your risk so
much more effectively because we won't
charge you
anything to be able to do that from a
from a risk management perspective
so in its kind of simplest sense that's
where we're really trying to get to with
that
um you know we we offer um
derivatives you know across a range of
different functions
if we look just at that sort of
perpetual futures piece we will have
dated futures as well but if we use that
perpetual features piece which is the
common products
you know across the crypto space it's
it's using that product against your
your core position that we that we
really think will benefit but also
you understand that if you have that
position how we're going to manage that
through time
um you know if you if you use a lot of
capital
by trading futures um we're not gonna
we're not gonna try and
benefit from you if you if you
if you run up against uh you know a
headwind that you really weren't
predicting
um and so the liquidation process that
we're on is extremely fair extremely
transparent
we don't we're not taking positions off
you that we would then try and benefit
from like selling those out in the
market at a different price
we actually make the whole liquidation
process transparent and clear
and we make it a um we make it a
competitive process
you know prices are deemed by supply and
demand you can't have a fair price for
an asset unless there's
supply and demand you know vying to to
create that that equilibrium price
so in the same point we don't want to
take positions off customers if if there
isn't a competitive price to do it so
even to our liquidation process we use a
competitive price model to ensure that
any any position that's taken off you
because you can no longer afford to keep
it
is also done in a completely fair way um
and we actually we make no money from
any of the liquidation process
um you know that that's actually managed
by effectively external people
and to that point actually um as a as in
as a platform itself when i talked
earlier about us being utility
you know we we have a hard and fast rule
and we've made it public
um in our statements to the sec and and
as part of our process for for getting
listed
we don't market make on our own exchange
so we are never counterpart to any of
your trades
um on our public exchange um we don't we
can't see it anyone who's on the
platform has no informational advantage
or disadvantage compared to ourselves
um it's we're trying to create that that
fair marketplace and that runs right the
way through from
the products we put on there to the way
those products are traded and if
unfortunately at any point a customer
can no longer afford to keep a position
open
then the process for which that position
is closed is again a fair and
transparent one
that we try and ensure um and and that's
that's really
the whole ethos behind behind this the
setup that we've got
so one of the things that's interesting
to me is basically as you build on a
product suite you get access to more
information as you get access to more
information you're able to
de-risk in some of these situations
you're able to have better clarity about
who the customer is what their portfolio
is what their risk exposure is
and so not only can you make one sounder
decisions but also too it changes the
cost structure right in terms of
you actually aren't kind of flying blind
and so i guess the question then becomes
as you build up that product suite how
important is it to really explain
the ecosystem to a prospective uh
customer or user rather than just say
hey come use our exchange or our custody
kind of a one-off product right it
really is there's
uh this value add almost or kind of can
lock it in the product suite that allows
you to be better
and better serve the customer if they
use all the products right
yeah and i think that's a really
important point you know when you have
your own
custodian our ability to
consider our counterparty bits to a
custodian
completely different to if we're using a
third party custodian
you know we acutely understand um the
way in which we've built that product
how that product is insured for example
um how that process happens
what the costs are for actually running
and managing their processes like the
true costs
not what we charge people but the
genuine true costs
and being able to see that there's
efficiencies that can be gained
but also thinking about the fact that
you know if you've bought
if someone comes to us with crypto
they've bought it somewhere
um so they've had an experience of
buying um
now that means that they will probably
at some point want to buy some more or
possibly sell it so
they need you know a venue for doing
that but also they need a venue for
storing it whilst they're waiting to do
that
now one of the areas that we're
extremely interested in um
and we've had an announcement earlier
this you know beginning this year is
around what you can do within the
learning and borrowing space how you can
be more efficient
not just how we can be efficient with
your assets but how you can be efficient
with your assets
um the concept of lending assets and
borrowing assets and traditional
finances
is um is well known fairly well
understood
even within the traditional retail bank
that's effectively the model
you know your net interest margin for a
bank is effectively where they
take money off people like you and i
instead of their accounts and where they
lend it out to other people
you know to for whatever reasons it
might be buying houses
um corporate debt um the
the interesting thing that's at the
moment is a lot of people sit and hold
crypto for the fundamental reasons that
we
mentioned earlier but it's sort of
sitting as a dead asset
and that's something that we also want
to change so how can
how can you earn by just holding crypto
and how can we do that again in a safe
way that allows people to understand
what we're doing with their products
um but at the same time allows them to
to generate a return on a product that
doesn't naturally inherently have
unlike say you know fiat currency which
is really just trying to
want to stand still a lot of the time
when it comes to
um you know to inflation rates and
interest so
for us you know we're in the process of
rolling out a product that allow people
to
earn whilst they do nothing but at the
same time have access to all of that
ecosystem that we talked about the
custody piece the trading piece
um you know even some more complex
trading strategies that we make
available for people through algorithms
or
sort of um automated trading processes
um
and bring all that together so that
really you're you're comfortable that
your assets are held in a safe and
secure manner
you have access to liquidity as and when
you want it your assets are working for
you even when you're not touching them
um and you're doing that all in the
system that all understands each other
can all speak to each other
but as i mentioned before we're not
ignorant to the fact that there are
other venues out there
and so you know we're comfortable as
well that you say
you know i've traded on another platform
up for a long time
i'm comfortable there um have a look at
what you guys can do and we have the
experience you have with us and
and what you see the way we do things we
do things differently we'll slowly see
you
migrate your business over but we
understand that those currently exist
and we're not saying you know okay
because you want to use another venue
we're now going to exclude you from
everything we did
so it's it's take as much as you can and
take as much as you want because you'll
feel you'll truly feel a benefit for it
or from doing so um but we're not gonna
cast you aside because you say actually
you know i still use a custodian here or
i still use a trading system there you
know that that's
um you know that would be a pasta
disaster for us
for sure how do you think uh being based
in asia is an advantage
helps you think differently than maybe
some of the other products that uh that
people are used to using
is there anything that kind of sticks
out in your mind about the geographic
location
either of you and other people in the
team's experience over the years in
finance kind of working in various
cities
across asia or also just living there
now and kind of
spinning day to day um i love living in
asia and
lived there for the last 15 years and
thoroughly enjoyed my entire time
um i think there's definitely some
experiences that that we
use and in particular around that
derivative speech so as i mentioned
earlier you know
you need that derivatives piece really
um offer the entire spectrum of risk
control risk management and exposure
um but building just you know
if i build it will they come that
concept doesn't work so well
now you need to understand why people
are coming and
in asia there's the
traditional finance there's an extremely
prevalent structured products market
um and that's primarily driven by
retail investors effectively using
structured products to get exposure that
they
they want in traditional financial
markets you know be it through
fx or equities or worm or other products
um and knowing to them that you know
that they're generating the return and
they're giving themselves certain
pathway or structure through that
product
but that really is bringing off the side
of the volatility market
which is the measure of you know how
options are priced
and extremely um
really interesting that is that it's
actually the
almost the tail that whacks the dog in
asia when it comes to the volatility
markets what prices options it's the
retail guys who are selling
are actually determining the price for
the which computations trade volatility
all the way up to index level um
and we've seen that and we've
experienced that
we've sat there you know on derivatives
trading desks in asia and watched as
this
buyer of retail capital infrastructure
products that has proven
institutional trading um
and so what we're doing with our
investment products division which is
again a kind of key part of this
building is putting together those
those structured products that can be
distributed by the wealth management
platforms
and private banks to those same
investors
and and what that will do is bring back
into the exchange
all of the volatility that they're
selling the offer side of those options
and so we understand you need both sides
you can't just build an exchange and
expect google trade you need
someone to buy and someone sell and
really that that experience in asia
structural product market
and having hired a great team to build
that forest
um that's where we think we're going to
differentiate ourselves in
in the options market because we know
how to bring both sides of the trade
there
there's plenty of people who want to
trade volatility trade options on
if i want to buy calls or ipods and i
get that sort of explosion
finding the other side of that a little
bit more difficult understanding that
that comes from the retail piece
packaged and restructured through the
structured product market is i think
a key difference and one of the key
things that we've all experienced from
our time in asia
yeah that's a really unique insight i
think and
one that obviously has played well for
you guys
before we go to wrap up i want to
quickly just talk to people about
uh where they can find you on the
internet and where they can find diginex
the products
go learn more about them or sign up if
they'd like
actually yeah i mean one of the things
that's
interesting for us we're after talents
we're after
great people and we want people to come
and join us we want people to want to
come and join us and i know that it's
something you just started
you know looking at in terms of that
time acquisition the financial services
industry suffered a huge brain drain to
tech
you know particularly post gfc what we
want to do is start to
let people see that tech and financial
services are mutually exclusive
and if you want to do something right
you want to do it differently you can
still do that in a financial services
company and you can still
you know be the best of that and do it
in a way that is um
you know that is pleasing to yourself
and the satisfaction everything that
that brings um and so really for us
talent acquisition right now
is a key thing for us um you can come
and see our products
equest.io diginx.com um
everything's available there we're on
linkedin we're on social media you know
there's there's opportunities to get to
us we have a telegram channel that
everyone's welcome to look at and see
some of the conversations that we're
having there
um but we really do want to talk and
engage with people and particularly
those people
um who feel that they've got something
to add in this space and and we are
we are genuinely open to having a lot of
conversations with people
um about how we can you know continue to
build out the product suite the offering
you know the platform um you know to to
really establish ourselves as that that
core provider of a quality platform a
quality
product within the industry yeah
i highly suggest people go check it out
so i i love that perspective
uh i always ask everyone the same three
questions and get to ask me one to
finish
up first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
um it's a good question um
i had a i personally i thoroughly enjoy
reading um
biographies autobiographies or memoirs
in fiction
and i've just recently finished one
based on the diaries of winston
churchill during the blitz
and looking at how people reacted to
what he was saying
and how he was working with you know the
american government
at the time to try and encourage them to
help the british during the war
uh how his features were being met both
in parliament and by
individuals within the um within the uk
and how they're responding to that
and also then how that had an effect on
on the uk's ability to sort of manage
its way through that
he to me he's one of the most
interesting orators out there
um and nice naturally
gifted uh communicator and and so to
read how that process went through and
and the way he thought about it and how
much time and effort went into thinking
about those things at the time when the
whole world was under such duress
is extremely interesting for me and has
had a reasonably
profound impact i am i'm the same way
i love reading biographies of successful
people
um so i fully understand that uh second
question
is a little bit more personal sleep
schedule and this is brought to you by
uh our friends at eight sleep they've
got this like thermoregulation
bed that i sleep on every night which
basically just makes it really really
cold
uh which helps you sleep deeper and also
i start sleeping
eight hours a night and feel amazing
compared to when i sleep five or six are
you a
three or four hour sleeper or more like
a nine or ten hour sleeper
um i'm one of those people who looks at
my watch when i go to bed
and panics if there's not eight hours
before i need to get off
amazing i'm also one of those people who
wants it to be extremely cold so i am a
huge fan of any thermal regulated pet
sadly my wife isn't this is
operationally completely different scale
dividing
and i think we're one of the people
you know there's an electric blanket in
our room and my side has never even had
the plug attached to it this is on nine
months of the year and
we operated a very different way in that
sense so i'm definitely eight hours i
think i can't
um to my kids you know sleep's the most
important thing
um really because without enough sleep
you really can't operate so
yeah i i'm i'm always amazed at those
people who can get by on 3 or 4 hours
because that's not me unfortunately
yeah i used to try but not anymore i'm a
full-on convert to the sleep religion
for sure
uh last question is more fun aliens are
you a believer
or a non-believer
um look
based on the laws of probability i have
to be a believer
um you know for me everything's about
you know the chance of things happening
and probability and everything i do in
work every day is looking at the
probability of an event happening and
whether or not
you know the expected result is positive
or negative off the back of that
so just based on the sheer scale and
scope of what's beyond just this planet
i i would have to say i believe um
i don't know i don't have a strong view
on the form or the process
um but absolutely one of those things
whereby you'd have to say i'm completely
not surprised
at one point when this happens because
you know that
the scale to which um to which the whole
universe operates means it has to be
there
i i i'm uh uh your spirit animal
on the other side of the world because i
i completely agree it's just not from a
probability standpoint i don't know how
anyone thinks uh
they don't exist i don't know if they've
shown up i don't know if they're little
green men that get out of ufos
but uh but definitely there's got to be
life somewhere right
absolutely you know we were having a
conversation with my kids about how life
started and
um indigenous people different lands and
we were sort of
trying to go through this process and
you know and how it got there and
and the fact that even just in the world
you know on one side of the world versus
other
how these events sparked and now you
know expand that not just within the
guys with the universe and beyond that
you suddenly realize that um you know
it's just impossible for it not to be
the case
for sure what uh what's the one question
you got for me to finish up
um so i'd probably embarrass myself
slightly earlier
with tom goose and believe me it's more
maverick than tom cruise
per se so i'm in a similar vein to your
books but what's the movie
that got you the way you are because for
most people these days it is a film or a
movie
yeah i don't know if i've got uh like
one movie where it was like hey here's
the thing
um and you know i'm gonna go pursue that
um
i think that i probably have
uh a couple of different movies that
people um might not have ever heard of
or may not have put as much importance
on them as i did
um but the two that immediately popped
to mind
are uh there's this movie called four
brothers uh
it's got mark wahlberg tyrese a bunch of
uh of kind of actors and the whole idea
is basically they're four
orphans right or kind of adopted kids
that end up in the same house they go
off
in a kind of pretty hard life in detroit
uh they all kind of disperse and they
come back
and uh and basically they're just
kicking ass together right and it's like
look we're not brothers actually but
they call each other brothers and i grew
up in a family with five boys so that
movie always kind of
was cool to watch with uh with my actual
brothers uh and then the other movie
um and probably my favorite movie ever
is this movie uh called
in time um it's got a justin timberlake
in it which immediately is like a
polarizing 50 50 whether people like it
or not just because he's involved
um but i think that the message behind
the movie it's basically everyone has
a um a clock in their forearm
and uh when you go to work you don't get
paid in money you get paid in time
and so literally as you leave the
factory they like put more time on your
clock
if your clock ever hits zero you die uh
but
if you are quote-unquote rich you have
unlimited amount of time and so it's got
all these like metaphors for life like
one of the things is there's zones
uh or neighborhoods and based on how
much time you have you can go in between
the zones or you cannot
um and so he has no time he gets a bunch
of time he goes to the rich area
and the first thing he realizes is uh in
the
poor area where people don't have any
time they run everywhere nobody walks
everyone runs
but when he gets the rich area nobody
runs everybody walks
and so he's like huh and then he
realized oh because i run everywhere
because i'm always trying to save time
right i'm always trying to like get to
a job get more work and stuff so i think
like a a movie like that which
you know frankly nobody even really
knows about uh it's just really got a
great message and kind of reminds you
that like
time is the most scarce asset and so um
it kind of just centers you back on like
what's important
that was oddly enough i've seen both of
those films
amazing yeah amazing and i particularly
the process of transferring time with
that armed like sort of handshake that
they have in movies um
is quite an interesting one um and and
how it all works
but i'm one of those people who as we
talked about secretly
efficiency and efficiency is so key to
me
i like to be on time i don't like to be
early i don't like to be late i like to
be just on time i like to
try and do as many things as i can at
the same time or reduce the amount of
times i have to do something
with the way in which i work which
sometimes sort of frustrates my wife if
i
leave things in a pile because i'm gonna
move them all in one go rather than take
them one at a time
throughout the day um but yeah to me
it's a really scarce commodity and don't
pull off to tomorrow what you can do
today
i could not agree more my friend um all
right
we will send people go check out diginex
uh go look
at the uh stock what's the ticker on
nasdaq
eq os on nasdaq eq os
or equos.com as well so thank you so
much for doing this deal i really
appreciate it we'll do it again in the
future
thanks very much